okay guys this is your boy psychobabble
in this song and more importantly this
game let's call your left me let's see
how bad I guess yep very boring well
what is this power here toes Photoshop
Univ a c-sharp good for him
Oh studio aspire to five dissociative
amnesia
don't freak I can't forget you yep cats
go yell at me for 20 and 703 and that's
a day but seven I am Oh click on it and
I'm gonna work and I go to sleep at 10
okay waking up tomorrow I wake up in the
same bed but it don't work any and where
am i why am I here that's a really good
question
clock on on the moon clock that's what
our timer what happens when night falls
and the time runs up how do I get out of
here before that all right that's scary
how does the pancake wall white magnets
read what they've read they read how
what can't read them the words why don't
they mean a mess remember Swain's Lane
give this girl some milk tell him I love
you you know why what's Wayans laying
and I was going on physically working
again I can't focus
I've gone crazy a few times I get it how
does the pancake wobble the man has
asked the Frick I love you from who you
know we all who sicknesses your reads
remembers Wayne's land why there Nate
give this girl some milk wait can I do
open it though
find keys in there okay it's off to the
moon I mean rumbles how do you round up
37 sheep around a 40 talked to the moon
do you think a shower say they don't
forget to return it at this kidding
holy should get that scary you can't
wait this cat I love me like you I know
I feel comfortable and let me to pretend
so the same way advice eyeball pamper
him I will marry you platonically love
you thank you I've had him for one
even okay and I get it what what is this
now it's a hand what is this oh there my
phone on scene tax from his calls I were
looking fun anymore I trying to forget
throne where she contains brought so
much okay I'm in a bet when that one on
a bus
whoa
hey buddy hey what's up why I work today
I mean I just why here you would take
the day off for weeks now ever since I
mean yeah anyways why are you here freak
out what that was and making with it
might as well tell me you gotta go what
are you pêche or something well what's
going on this guy how many ants I got
yeah this job always there's always room
for improvement
you see what working late tonight that
sounds great
they're working six hours the working
filmin do allowed my thoughts to fetch I
kept thinking about it you better get to
thinking about it yeah and I got that
job okay I'm not gonna let you out that
is a good these guys just go back to
work you don't want to eat drop to first
ready crazy
and we're hello that's disgusting
it's gone what dekinai can we got a
couple choices here it's cute one last
work like swing slate I remember it now
hey that of all gonna be done it ever
since but yeah that one that what do you
make stuck in my head loving a knife and
I said there's social reality they can't
you left me the flower fields that past
the metro I loved and now he left my
band and I'm blind me by lightning
yeah you know a we can't think about
joining you time to survive buddy but
I'll keep looking at berries you get to
me without you okay I love air alright
that's that you left me thanks bro
yeah how'd you get that here I'm stuck
all right pace y'all help y'all enjoy
that a little weird but I was a king